jérôme rodrigues ne mâche pas ses mots
envers les forces de l'ordre
la figure du mouvement des gilet jaune a
publié un tweet incisif en réponse à un
message provocateur du syndicat de
police synergie officiers
il y qualifie ses interlocuteurs de
nazis et compare les locaux de police à
un camp de concentration
jérôme rodriguez fait ici référence à un
commissariat du xviiie arrondissement de
paris
utilisée lorsque la police procède à des
interpellations massives
un message qui ne passe pas auprès de
gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur a fait savoir
son intention de porter plainte
les propos de monsieur rodrigues envers
la police de la république sont ignobles
au nom du ministère et pour défendre
l'honneur de tous les policiers
je dépose plainte gérald darmanin
poursuites ainsi sa politique de
tolérance zéro contre les insultes
envers les policiers
le 26 juillet dernier le ministère de
l'intérieur avait annoncé porter plainte
contre le maire europe ecologie les
verts de colombes qui avait comparé les
forces de l'ordre qui traque les
migrants aux policiers et gendarmes qui
ont participé à la rafle du vel d'hiv
face à ces menaces de poursuites jérôme
rodrigues lui contre attaque
quelque part c'est du corporatisme c'est
normal qu'ils défendent ces policiers
c'est d'aumale c'est normal qu'ils
défendent ces petites demoiselles
d'honneur qui était présente
armés jusqu'aux dents autour de son
mariage elle leur doit bien ça quand
même hein c'est normal donc dans
l'absolu ça me dérange pas plus
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire me prendre
ce que j'ai plus me prendre plus qui
m'ont enlevé aujourd'hui dans ma vie
amusez vous en même temps vous êtes en
train de gâcher l'argent du contribuable
pour des petites injures ce que
j'appelle les embrouilles de sucettes et
de vol de bonbons à la récré je pense
qu'il serait peut-être plus intéressant
de mettre dans l'argent à améliorer
aujourd'hui votre police et de faire
ensemble de virer tous ces personnes qui
mettent justement à mal l'image de la
police une tension qui s'intensifie un
peu plus entre eux jérôme rodriguez et
les forces de l'ordre à la veille de la
reprise de la mobilisation des gilet
jaune